John do you want to go over
Moon yeah absolutely Roxy I do or would
you rather go
underworld
oh you I walked right into that one you
really did you set me up perfectly Roxy
you you stumped me there it's
runy here back in action oh we we take
them off and then we put them back on
whatever you want
yeah cool people do whatever they want
with their sh yeah well you know what
else cool people do they watch
underworld Evolutions that's right you
know what else cool people do what do
they do they leave a like on this video
they subscribe they hit the
notification that's what the coolest of
cools do The Cools you want to know the
best part about wearing sunglasses what
is it roxan that nobody there's going to
know when I read the next part because I
still have it learned it yo you want to
be a super sexy reject go over to
patreon that's where the full length
reaction walks to Longs are where you
sink up with your own copy that's just
for the sexy ones true that the cool
sexy sexiest ones ooh sexy and cool all
in one package you can't beat it over
there Greg and John cover several shows
exclusively with reaction highlights and
watch alongs included John we already
watched underworld one we did and now
we're going to have some more fun Under
World under Thunder World we're ready
for Thunder World which is also not as
underworld
evolution I likeed the first one a
little bit better than you did you know
revisiting that edit I uh it grew on me
that much more though eight centuries
ago unknown to humanity a blood Feud
raged between a ruling class of vampires
and a rebellious Legion of werewolves
known as lyans Legend tells that the War
Began with two brothers The Immortal
sons of Alexander corvinus Marcus bitten
by bat became the blood leader of the
vampires William bitten by woles became
the first and most powerful lyan how was
fire bro dude narrating team are we the
two brothers we're the two
brothers all right 13th century let's do
this thing my god brother what have you
done it almost looks like Planet of the
Apes it's him Burton
version or L plan of the Apes little
Lord of the Rings too way more that I
will not tolerate this any longer Marcus
your brother Must Be Stopped what's the
accent it's just Bill Nye accent is he
still here yes he must not be harmed but
William must be controlled this William
Guy give me the
torch whoa yeah let's
go they're
turning
uh-oh
oh
oh that was pretty cool
actually yeah I wonder how they'll build
on the Transformations and stuff this
time yeah oohoo not bad couple years can
make a big difference with movies like
this with
technology oo
oo blood baths in the snow are always
cool visually on screen with all the red
and the white yeah show us the
aftermath that's why I wish they would
make a whoa damn dude going
hard wo that's interesting that we just
saw the splash on camera as if it was
like part of the scene yeah getting that
be movie aesthetic yeah get a little
grind
house
whoa give it kind of like a Jerky like
almost stop motion quality it hurt my
bones I will stay in fights you need my
help I need Let My People Go you die we
all die now go come on Marcus is that
guy from Game of Thrones no I think uh
maybe I think he's the guy who played
van goat Doctor Who and and and has been
in many other things did he have one or
two ears at the time
oo this reminds me of like a medieval
version of dog soldiers right now we
found him and we need more men find
Amelia Bedelia Amelia Bedelia she back
she got merked last time right Amelia we
found William that's Amilia yeah wasn't
she the one in the crazy dress who was
like arriving and then she got killed
yeah we were waiting for her and she got
killed on the train right
yeah Will I
Am drop the Beet now
oh can
be why leave him be they're supposed to
keep him
[Music]
alive jeez he was not to be harmed
Place him in my charge as we agreed or
you will pay for your deceit oh it will
be done my way you know well the
consequences if you murder
me oh boy what is thy will imprisonment
for all time for all time always hello
people only have empathy when it hits
close to home it's like you had no
problem wiping out everybody else but
his brother I was a loyal soldier of the
vampire CL right where we left
here right where we found him
betay last time on underworld Craven's
lust for power and domination had failed
always do Victor was not the Savior I
had been led to believe what do you
think of this kind of flashback shot
like what do you call this no just the
the way that they're showing it the like
slow blur yeah this like filter they
have over everything kind of dreamy lens
effect I have but one Ally left Michael
your boy the human descendant of
corvinus Scott Speedman neither vampire
nor Lan but a
hybrid it's mlen it's only a matter of
time before we're
found yeah it's like they put a motion
Zoom effect on it totally it's kind of
weird last time I told you he did so
much good for Alzheimer's research you
said really is his character yeah I'm
crazy now I thought Scott spean was out
here helping out he might be out in
these streets doing doing good he might
be hope now is to awaken Marcus our last
remaining Elder and expose the truth but
we just saw Marcus before Craven tries
to murder him while still in hibernation
waking up Craven knows he's no match for
him
awake but asleep let me tell you I'll
take them I like how much lore they put
in just that beginning part they're like
we're going to jam this in now you have
this information now we can move forward
let's go I hope we get more of that like
it's cool to see them like way back when
and like and all that stuff you know
like the futuristic cyber Punk stuff is
also cool but you know yeah I like it
the medieval
yeah just Let the Rain Fall Down an
atmosphere it's like a '90s music
video whoa this thing's been dead for
weeks the Lans went back to their human
form when they die they do this one's
been given a serum to stop regression so
it can be studied how can you
tell says so on this paper
there only about an hour till daylight
can you even make it back to the mansion
Before Sunrise just let's get what we
need and go no I'm going alone no dude
she's making the same mistakes as last
time learned your lesson gir on open
it m for Marcus M for my
man is this Aquaman once we get down
there that's right yeah Jason moo is
going to be down there just like Johnny
Depp he's like what making all kinds of
inappropriate
jokes I just like this world yeah this
underworld got some good underworld
building oh he already out he's
waiting
whoa whoa
nice
wo oo yeah waa this is gnarly
who cool po
yeah
oh not
craving the blood memories of this
wretched cre Creer have shown me that
your treachery knows no bounds I can
explain can you why would I listen to
your lies get him Marcus when the
journey to the truth but your brother
man is in your death so much
sweeter
oh nice you'll go before Victor and tell
them exactly what I tell you
to you just concentrate on your part
blood memories smart expositional
recap I can assist you all you already
have
Oh I thought he was going to be in this
movie it's been a while since I've seen
like an 80s dispatch of a central
character from the previous movie look
go I'll be here you just make sure you
come back they are so white yes contrast
is so high yeah the innocent who
witnessed they've been silent but
otherwise unharmed as ordered you cared
about them being unharmed that's nice
two death dealers were killed we found
no liken bodies they were using a new
kind of ammunition some sort of UV round
Amelia those UV rounds boy it seems
Craven's men might have been present but
they did nothing to prevent it and
Victor and no trace of Mark amongst the
ashes seems he destroyed his own coven
sir never his coven
ow cool look I bet they use olive oil
for the Slime just make them look all
greased I've decided I'm a Lykan now I I
took it back first time I chose vampire
and I chose
poorly yeah something's
up
what are you a
doctor
wowe that had to have been installed no
right it's an arc reactor maybe that's
why he said you know the consequences if
you kill us or something there's
something to it yeah it's going to have
something to do with
that
have you been awake recently enough to
understand this
machine there you are maybe he figured
out when he sucked the blood it came to
him technology keyboard oh there you go
absorbed all those memories of
typing all that data entry that Craven
was
doing
do not drink one of their
[Music]
blood how do you be able to fly Marcus
all of them that can he's ancient man I
don't know they grow wings over time
from the get but some of them don't he I
wonder what the rules are yeah how you
get your
wings yeah it's not filling him do you
at least get the
taste I would do what he's doing though
I wouldn't just accept somebody telling
me I had to eat blood or I wouldn't get
full I would try yeah I know
totally question is it just going to be
the food or is it going to be like a
geyser of
blood whoa what is it he can't process
it
uhoh get away from
me I would get away from him bro cops
are stupid everywhere yeah get away from
him they're none the wiser to the world
that lurks
underneath damn you
man oh yeah oh
no oh at least he still got his
reflection is that a vamp thing yeah I
don't I don't think in this universe but
you know in classic lore oh that looked
[Music]
painful let him
go yeah I was going to say you're kind
of close to Daylight do you think he can
be in the daylight that's a good
question oo yes we about to find
out oh yeah see she has no wings but
she's got flyness feel like wings at
come with like being
ancient
oh yeah
nice nicely
done take it no Michael you'll die maybe
I want to die so you can just drink
other vampires blood if you need I guess
in this world you can oh wow it feels
good for her probably okay that f face
this is wild we're watching the most
with no this is how Vamps do it yeah I
know what you've done Seline Victor
deserved his fate and Craven was no
better Craven has already reaped the
rewards of his own misdeeds Victor
deserved his fate Victor was a dictor
why are you guys so anti- dictators
imagine if America was a
dictatorship what do you suppose Victor
had to hide Perhaps it is you
SEL oh
n dude yes are you
dumb it's got to protect his
[Applause]
Bay
who
[Music]
oh whatever you want
Lady can he fly as fast yeah okay oh
[Music]
yeah them
hops kind of looks like
Avatar
[Applause]
oo
dang wow that was wild Dead or Alive you
will give me what I want Dead or Alive
you're coming with me Marcus I feel like
you'd be on her same side she's waking
up to the treachery and deceit and all
that is she going to turn and go be
close to William maybe maybe she likes
the Wolves yeah
maybe maybe they have a
baby
oh
a Wings having trouble they wanted this
why I don't know did you realize that
no so what was that little thing that he
wanted that little pendant keep your
foot on the gas stay
down get
[Music]
down
jeez I can't even get a guy to like
bring me te just going to splash splash
black paint all over the
windows luckily this place is filled
with cans of black paint I like that
it's working it's like be right
back oh
no you see those are movies I've never
seen one in real life though what first
aid kid on the bathroom wall
yeah
see no need but I appreciate the thought
she's like I know more than you do still
I think he's
nervous I would be too she's a smoke bro
y
yeah yeah get that romance love L sh
[Laughter]
ship still a better love story than
Twilight
I'm so happy right now I've been wanting
this for so long all movie one and the
first 40 minutes of this
movie you can just check out from here
on woe wow they're really dang dog wow
okay they're making it happen what is
this movie rated I don't know but the
placement is like perfect so they really
that could go on somebody's wall yeah
every frame of
painting
oh heal yourself his design is very
[Music]
Sinister area secure
sir blow it up blow it up watch it all
fall out with my handy tap light
bomb I was like oh is it not going to
explode yeah like who are they trying to
gas right
now
yep I've seen this before when I was a
child when it was open like this how's
that possible but I know someone that
might classic movie Andreas Tannis he's
the official historian of the covs
Tannis drink your Tannis root he was
exiled over 300 years ago what makes you
think we're going to find him now I was
the one who exiled him I was going to
say do you know how old everyone around
you is is cuz you're like the youngest
person by a miles a baby honestly she's
crle
robbing looks like a monastery it used
to be more like a prison now tennis has
been hiding there since Victor's order a
pisaster good one bro thanks dog KN I
can count on you for support for real
soups BR I don't remember this gate
being here
before do you have memories from 300
years ago that are that clear I don't
think this gate was one time 300 years
ago I stopped by I remember all my Gates
you know wowe okay so boobies this is an
R-rated movie but not Kate's boobies
well yeah cuz she too famous that's
right
[Music]
man go back oh I was going to say is
there a
trapo dam
whoa my guy
[Music]
Sam so he was exiled but he has a and
he's a vampire but he has a wolf with
him the story of the hybrids and the
intermingling between The Vamps and the
lykans is clearly more dubious than we
first
thought
whoa he's got that same mask as the one
that was tied
up
ah
whoa It's your guard
dogs D that was sweet she's dope
yeah you think they brush their wolf
teeth oh they must got to keep them
clean you know or at least they get
those dog bones that clean the teeth you
know some you said do they what that's
what I was s about look at his teeth
they look a little
yell oo
boy oh yeah they don't know they're
going up against a hybrid
[Music]
bro
oh
jeez wow that was quick I like that they
had time to put clothes on but not all
the
clothes you don't scare me Seline well
we're going to have to work on that o
boom that is a vampire of Len bodyguards
a gift from a most persuasive client
Lucian why would Lucian want to protect
you because he was trading with
them oh snap how long have you been in
the business of killing your own kind
I've done what's necessary to survive my
decision was made easy the day your
precious Victor betrayed me your own
kind bro Victor's dead I killed him no I
think not oh unless you've learned the
truth careful with that here makes a
terrible bang open the blades and
they're active good to know that'll come
back later Marcus was after this
why one of your
pendants he knows how to make an
entrance yeah jeez Victor was not the
first of our kind as he were led to
believe he was once human the ruler of
these lands oh damn he is the
one the source the first true vampire Oh
Marcus came reprieve refuse from
sickness and death and in return Victor
was to use his army turned Immortal to
help him to defeat the very first
werewolves created by Marcus's own flesh
and
blood his twin brother William they at
least are evolved never able to take
human form again and William's Appetite
for Destruction Rampage was insociable
sheepers so once Victor's Army was
turned the legions of vampires under his
control tracked down and destroyed the
animals then captured William Victor's
prisoner for all time always William's
death would mean the end for all lians
his slaves yes a clever deception they
did that in the originals which came
after this it's Williams prison the
prison your father was commissioned to
build oh no
so you've been the one keeping a watch
over this for me have you searching
everywhere for this my
darling Oh my God the only one still
living who has seen its location but
Marcus knows that the memory therefore
the exact location of William's prison
is in your blood is hidden away in your
blood why is Marcus looking for him now
that I cannot answer he just wants to
see his bro again but I do know someone
who could stop him perhaps I could
arange your meeting yes in exchange for
your discretion just let me stay exiled
who's the meeting with bro what blade I
was thinking that crossover finally
apparently they wanted to do a crossover
and it didn't
happen yeah that's going to help no my
dude Victor struck two keys what do you
know of them I don't know of any key bad
liar oh yeah one was kept in plain sight
draped around his daughter's neck and
the other kept with Victor at all times
where within him up his butt beneath the
FL
yes no
no no go to Pier 17 ask for Loren mararo
no Loren has one of them the other one
cuz he took it from Victor's inside but
who is Loren
why is he have skin in this game what's
tough for our boy Tannis just now is he
can't kill Marcus because then everybody
he dies so you're like defenseless
[Music]
right you're familiar with this then
intimately up you're
behind how intimately you're Alexander
keness oh oh oh I knew it had to be
some kind of Alias centuries I've stood
by and watched the Havoc my sons have
wrought upon each other and upon
Humanity so he's the dad of William and
Marcus you are asking me to help you
kill my son how many Innocents did you
kill in the sixth Century quest to
avenge your family you are no different
from Marcus and even less noble than
William boom hundreds of thousands have
died because of your inability to accept
that your sons are monsters you know the
station William caused before he was
captured he cannot be set free but what
is he he's Immortal at
least I mean if if Vamps and wolves both
stem from him I I don't know maybe he's
just pure
evil
whoa way to hook him
yeah
ow what no wait no no match for
him ah ah she's like watch me boo yeah
yeah
oh ow little
painful
brother
[Music]
oh that's swing
nice
yeah oo no
yeah that's going to
help ooh oh no damn
it oh
God no no no they're gone they there my
child you are safe
now a
craven
oh this guy's looking everybody's
personal
business oh right in the mouth in the
kisser she's going to pull it up and
through I feel like pull him up
oh you think he's going to make it yes
or no three two yes he's going to make
it he's going to make it now I changed
my mind they're definitely going to kill
him right here
oh
no
oh she finally found someone that she
chose don't worry there will be
something some magical thing maybe her
tears will bring him back true love's
kiss true love's kiss true love's
kiss
whoa oh wow you are unwelcome in my
presence this is a world for human human
it and that petty sentiment explains why
you stood by for over half a millennium
as William suffered alone in
darkness I have no respect for your
petty sentiment I get it yeah where's
your Humanity Dad if it was my brother
soon you'll be drowning in lyans just
like before are not lyans father a new
race created in the image of their maker
the new God
me ug man you made it so far don't kill
your dad oh he going to and the true
[Music]
God has no
father
ah damn it I guess you're not Immortal
my
dude in his pocket as said dad you got
to kind of feel proud that your kids
love each other that much right
especially if you neglected them I'm not
sensing that emotion
but oh my dude get the kit no he wants
to die find the girl bring her to me
before I pass out and die jeez if you
want Marcus you'll need Alexander's help
don't leave him here devastating we
didn't even get to see One More Kiss
it's okay it's not okay he might get
better you never know did he get
dependent
yes he's too powerful for you alone
excellent pep talk you are the Last Hope
left there is only one way to defeat
him with his blood oh boy what will I
become yeah that's what I was wondering
bro the future okay that's not really a
clear answer oh
snap you will be a God she was like
that's an acceptable answer what like
does she see from him
oh
yeah centuries of pain and
Agony he's himself I guess
so CU he doesn't want to see What
Becomes of the world without his sons or
with his sons yeah he's lived
enough
oh
damn I feels like an unnecessary thing
to do to your surroundings now
everybody's going to have to deal with
that he's probably got all sorts of
Secrets and stuff hidden on that ship
just got to obliterate all of
it it's some show like Game of Thrones
Penny Dreadful something I don't know
Tony Curran is that his
name so will can't turn back into man
right at this phase that they stay Beast
yeah at least as far as they've told
us just full wolf all the
time nice very spooky I don't see a way
inside there used to be a River entrance
just there it must be submerged now
looks like we're getting wet yeah that's
what she said
a thanks
bud oh damn what I mean he said looks
like we're getting wet that was pretty
sweet can vampires not just breathe
underw I mean she didn't take the mask
so maybe I don't know what are the rules
of breathing in this universe this is
what you guys all talk to me about at
home I had so many questions you
couldn't possibly know the answer
to just want your thoughts man
I'm so effing stoked right now what like
is he going to he's reading a book
inside chilling he's got little bifocals
on what if he's not in there there's a
fireplace teacup
William bro n it's me bro my bad for
taking so long I'm a little late she was
breathing just there so I guess you can
just hold her breath for a really long
time
who that is a cool looking wolf damn I'd
no sooner harm you than
myself oh it's sweet it's giving
Brotherly Love yeah I get it my dude I
wouldn't let my brother just be you know
it's not his fault yeah it's the way is
it he is can't control
it what is that nothing let's go likely
story should take your artwork
okay we're too
late woof ah damn
it whoa
damn oh he's like why are you so strong
yeah
[Music]
damn oh
no damn
it come on Hulk out
boy
Whoa decent CG I think so too for 2006
Michael you're unique
yeah there's never been a hybrid
before but then I thought homeboy's a
hybrid
oh you're Bradley Cooper and Limitless
let's do this where is he he went right
through there I thought he was going to
get a line I know he didn't get a sag
card on this man give him a speaking
roll yeah one
line
set designs are really cool yeah I was
just thinking that man I wonder what it
looked like on actual
set damn still no wine thanks you are
not allowed to make a sound you all
right answer him
oh
no oh no
no oh Big Willie
damn that is a cool looking
[Music]
wolf
nice yeah that cool cool reload oh
that's how she did it
[Music]
yeah yeah I kind of feel bad for him
though he's like I get out of this cage
y'all came to attack me I haven't even
done anything yet I might have changed
in the last I don't know thousands of
years
yeah
now he did Kill A lot of them
though this reminds me of a Devil May
Cry game a little bit
whoa she's destroying what her dad built
I mean I'm still on our team obviously
but I'm not you can't def face
architecture in my
presence want the snowfall
too
oh
no well these weren't the like we know
these were raging unable to take human
form ever
again yeah this ain't going to go
well but why was he able to take human
form well no but he's turning oh now
they're turning yeah yeah yeah they're
turning cuz they yeah just got slashed
up two no
yeah
ow wow that look sick man I really think
that looked sick yeah that was pretty
legit hey as y
boy oh yeah just reach your hand on
through
oh
jeez oh my
God can they kiss first Michel thank
goodness you interrupted
bro oh it's not that heavy quit
exaggerating in some water
bro
yeah is that help from up
there oh hey there oh he's going to pull
them down
whoa
no
no whoa whoa
whoa yeah I'd move z
um wow yo Cape beckan sail is a true
action star sure with a great stunt
woman I wonder how much of the stunt she
threw down
on demo him
bro oh we don't need a haircut
today your hair looks
bomb Oh damn
ow Indiana Jones
them got
hops this would be a gross gross ass
death
whoa theoretically that would grow back
right
wa oh my God oh my God oh no I knew
Victor made a mistake by keeping you as
a pet he should have killed you with the
rest of your family you're too much of a
threat
[Applause]
nice oh
man and they lived in peace happily ever
after oh
no she can walk in the daylight
now she Avenged her family's death took
care of the world she can be in the sun
maybe get a tan she needs
it oh she's so happy oh I'm so happy for
her dude and for them oh oh as she's
crying oh my God yeah to get that to get
that one tiar at the right time and also
do a kiss like wait I'm stoked bro you
could end the franchise here and I be
stoked I'm stoked that it doesn't end
here but that was perfect oh no don't
take don't take this from me m eerie
music yeah are we going to pull out from
a a snow globe the lines that had
divided the Clans have now been blurred
chaos and infighting are inevitable oh
do they all die cuz they killed them
darkness is still ahead but for now I
look into the light with New
[Music]
Hope yeah you do cuz theoretically
aren't they all supposed to die if if
the originator of their bloodline dies
but maybe that was just a rumor Danny
McBride it's that Danny McBride Roxy
it's the one all movies TR wait can you
acknowledge what I'm saying right now
though yes yes yes yes I think if I
remember correctly that scene it was
established that that yeah like it was
they wouldn't take the risk in case it
was true but it might not have been true
I guess or is it not true because she's
the original immortal because she took
the blood of homeboy and as long as
she's around now is she the originator
and now she can't
die that's a good question maybe in the
next couple of installments they will yo
let's go sequel okay all right
underworld Revol underworld evolution
Evolution a revolution it was that too
yes Evolution huh so they evolved yeah
in what way
uh well you know she evolved cuz she got
that originator blood uh and you know
Scott speedman's already been evolved
okay so we knew it was Kate we know it's
Scott is it Tony Karan we know it's
underworld
[Laughter]
evolution that would be a good pull hey
it is him Ron joxy Ron joxy pulling it
together that was really just the John
part
Joy okay we both recognized the was
really really good I want to see what
he's from uh wow okay yeah and hit us
with those Tunes so initial first like
right after watching the second one
liking it equal level a little less a
little more how you
feeling um that's a great question I I'm
almost curious more to hear yours I mean
I feel like these movies are sort of
different in that the first movie takes
a bit more
space to breathe and a bit more space to
be uh I don't know even what the word is
there's just more kind
of like direct scene work in the first
one like it breathes between the action
whereas this one is much more sort of
like we hit the ground running and the
action is mounting and mounting and
mounting until the end and it's also
like a bit of a shorter movie so in some
ways like I kind of enjoyed them both
equally for slightly different reasons
but like uh it's it's pretty close it's
pretty close I think I don't know how
people generally feel about this one
versus the first one I know people seem
to love rise of the lyans um that's the
third one which we will get to if you
guys like comment sub and give us love
anyway and actually only because Prime
is trying to make us watch underworld
Awakening right now I wonder if it's not
the third one but it's it's a prequel I
guess and it's yeah it's the one
everybody seems to really love but it's
not the third I'm not sure I like it's
again it's just cuz Prime is telling us
to watch something different now
bless um but I enjoyed this immensely
what did you think I thought that it had
a lot um writing on it because I loved
the first one and then going into this I
was like okay so I know I love these
characters are they going to be able to
perform the same kind of way and I think
that they did made some really smart
choices with the story that I was
thoroughly invested in like they already
had me with the characters so they could
kind of have a little more fun with the
story and do you know I love asking
questions there was a lot of things they
didn't answer until halfway through
three quarters of the way through you
know like they it didn't spoon feed its
audience like oh we want to give you all
the information at top yeah and I loved
that and I love that I still am curious
like okay all the stuff is kind of lore
to them as well they're like oh do we
die if the Bloodlines die how did that
come to be or like even Victor saying
that he's the or not Victor um the one
that's oh Victor yeah was he the one who
said he was the original one and then it
ends up being Marcus he creates that
deception yes creates that so that's not
real and that happens in life sometimes
people lie yeah but that wasn't the
truth and in the first one we thought
that was the truth and this one we find
out that it's not the truth and that it
was Marcus and then yeah even like we we
meet the Marcus and uh and uh William's
dad and like they don't tell us
immediately who is this dude why is he
invested so I just I loved the pacing of
this I think that it all came in due
time and there was some really smart
stuff but overall I think I probably
like the first one better because I just
was more surprised than anything that
how good the movie was yeah and there's
a bit more meat on some of those bones
partly because they do have to set up
stuff not just modify stuff um cuz yeah
like I I think maybe pound-for-pound I
probably would prefer the first movie
slight L just because yeah it's a bit
more rounded um cuz this one's very
immediate although they they this
definitely felt like just an immediate
continuation from that first movie just
like oh this is just the story
continuing rather than like oh here's a
redefinition of some kind for part two
you know they like they feel very akin
to one another they feel naturally one
into the next um so in that way I'm not
sitting here like with yeah one feeling
distinct L you know vividly One Way
versus the other but yeah it's like this
one is moving a lot more quickly it's
got a bigger I think effects budget to
some degree or just effects have
advanced a little bit for sure with
wolfy gate I mean there's just so many
of them yeah they did a lot more
Transformations here yeah which I loved
and then also as you know lover of love
I'm a shipper of ships in the first one
I wanted them to get it on like Donkey
Kong yes so in this one they really came
through for me like I every time that I
was desperate to see them kiss or
whatever they did and and then some I
mean I was kind of surprised with how
how really hot this got that got steamy
man I forgot that this was rated art
this must be rated art like and vampire
stuff should I'm sorry I I know that
some people they don't watch these
movies for that but for me if you're
going to give me a vamp franchise and
you're not going to really give me that
Vamp I don't want it like sure and you
got two gorgeous human beings they have
more than two there's so many cuties in
this but like to watch them connect and
then that moment at the end that the
sunlight moment really did it for me
yeah imagine that feeling for hundreds
of years you have not been able to see
the sun yeah I love the sun man that
affected me and that moment kind of
catches you off guard too too because
it's like you've been conditioned to be
like oh no sunlight but then yeah
they they catch you with that whole like
oh you know and yeah it's it's just such
a small thing and and I think that was a
nice you know choice to have it just be
like oh we're just kind of contemplating
her hand in the light and even the color
temperature is warmer on her skin her
face looks more uh you know there's
there's more of that yellow kind of sun
Lighty tone yeah as opposed to all like
the Stark blue white light that they
have so much of the movie and I thought
that was like a nice film choice but
also a nice story Choice yeah it's being
more on that the story choices some of
it felt a little easy or cop outy like
the fact that she could just drink the
dad's blood and beat them drinking the
blood to get all the info oh oh well
yeah yeah she like you would just think
if he knew this whole time that somebody
drinking his blood would get like so
he's just never let anybody drink his
blood like and her drinking his blood
all of a sudden means that she can be a
day Walker she can beat his son she gets
all his powers like I don't think we've
seen that in the past where if you drink
somebody's blood because then if you
could do that she should just drink
Scott speedman's blood you know like
well it's because yeah it's because cor
Venus's blood is special and he's the
original you know but has nobody ever
drank his blood ever before that's
certainly what it reads like yeah cuz I
mean I'm sure he with given the attitude
he seems to have towards you know his
kids and their lineage and the
infighting between the lineage and all
that stuff it doesn't seem like he would
be anxious to give this power to many
people or to perpetuate this cycle um
and so yeah it makes sense in that
moment of like okay well here's your
kind of last ditch it's like somebody's
got to you know at least finish this
fight and uh and it seems like you are
at least becoming hip enough to the
truth of the matter and wanting to put
an end to all of this that you know I
guess it could be you it is a little bit
like she just takes a swig and then
she's like got all the abilities I
thought you would have to like drain my
dude or something like that but you know
like it's fine it I'm willing to forget
like it's it's that stuff and and like
revisiting cuz yeah I think you were you
were I I really enjoyed the first one I
think you were more chuffed in the
moment and then rewatching it for you
know to prep the video I was like this
is actually like this is grown that much
more on me and I think it's because
there is like a be movie there is like a
a kind of
exploitation kind of quality and there's
almost like a soap operatic thread in
there as well along with your like
Matrix PVC leather stuff and your you
know
vampire uh you know societies and your
werewolf maulings and stuff like that um
and so yeah I thought this one certainly
uh uh had a good amount of that kind of
you know yeah be movie quality
especially with developments like that
but not always like I don't know be B
movie is an interesting thing to like in
something to because liken uh because
sometimes it's an uh not a compliment
and sometimes it is and I feel like this
movie I appreciate its bovie aspects
they often can yes alleviate my urge to
nitpick certain things and I did
appreciate that at least with this they
really were committed to like keeping
that kind of World building going I
thought meeting the guy the exiled guy
who's now just kind of living his man
cave life you know out in this uh Tannis
I thought like that was cool and and
yeah getting this you get that brief
prologue where um you know they're all
in their yeah whatever that is it's like
the 1200s they're all in their like
armor and and you know you get that ad
bro yeah yeah so you get that like early
piece of the conflict and and something
to ground it in this like ancient
timelessness um and then yeah once you
get back to the present like not much is
really made out of Scott Speedman like I
I I part of me was expecting in this
movie that they might like add to his
design or or redesign him or something
so I kind kind of confused early on in
that one scene where Marcus is watching
all the videos um but yeah I feel like
you know he is kind of the least their
relationship is served in the movie but
like his involvement as a character
doesn't do a heck of a lot except for
until the end when he's able to you know
rip uh Williams head apart if the thing
through his stomach didn't kill him too
I'm curious like to what extent he is
I'm curious what the hybrid situation is
and what it implies I mean my guess is
that uh I'm yeah I'm sitting here going
do you get some aspects of each and and
not others or you fully both or cuz he
can be out in the sun and stuff like
that I assume he's got healing powers
although I don't know why it took him so
long as compared to Seline and it does
certainly seem like uh there are things
where I have questions about like well
when can you heal versus when can you
not like is it is do you have to be
dismembered to a certain extent and I
think he would have been in a weakened
State when he comes back down but he's
not in a weaken State we haven't seen
him had any blood so I don't know I want
to look up that dude and see what else
he's been in you said Doctor Who yeah he
was in a great Doctor Who episode where
he plays Vincent van Gogh um but yeah I
mean he's he's done tons and tons of
work I definitely definitely recognize
him from something specifically that's
not coming to me right now oh he's in
Ray Donovan for w he's been in
everything he's in secret Invasion he
was in your honor he's in the flash he's
in For All Mankind wow homeboy Works
seven episod ra Donovan oh boy well and
if you're going to swap you know you do
a Switcheroo for Bill Nike in this movie
and I thought he was a solid choice
because he's got a similar kind of profi
he's a bit younger but he does have more
and especially at the time you know he
feels like a sensible kind of stature of
actor to put in as that type of presence
if we're not going to have Bill Nye
especially because he was very good yeah
oh he's a great he's terrif he's yeah
he's always a great performer easily
this movie could be more cheesy and it's
not really sometimes I think that's the
magic cuz there is cheese and there is
the movie quality to it but it walks at
in line and it takes it
quite seriously and I think that can be
the Peril sometimes when you're taking
yourself real seriously but this manages
to do it in a way that never creates a
dissonance for me I'm never sitting here
watching this
going sometimes that seriousness can
cross over and it'll start to feel like
kids making a student film they think is
like so completely this matter great
yeah and impactful when really it's yeah
it's a suspense fantasy Eerie exciting
I like the last one category exciting
it's pretty exciting I would say this
movie was effing exciting it was I would
say Eerie is probably the the least
engaged of all these uh you know
descriptors cuz like they have they have
cool and creepy design work and stuff
like that but they're not really trying
to like spook you that much yeah but
they are trying to excite you and that
worked for me yeah any other major
thoughts on underworld evolution
goodness gracious I don't think so I
mean you know solid action great
production designs and stuff like that I
loved the use of snow I've always wished
they would make a Friday the 13th in the
snow don't tell them that you could
write it oh hey that's that's what do
that's what you just gave away the gold
for free I'll cut it out of the video we
can write it together yeah good point
any other underworld things you want to
see for sure in the future that we
haven't gotten in the first two
uh I just want another opportunity to
see Michael Sheen again that's the one
thing is is I was really sad there
wasn't really a way to finagle him into
this you know um obviously cuz he dead
and I was like I thought they were going
to find a like I would forgive them for
bringing him back if they wanted to and
if they do a prequel I have faith that
he might you know be involved with that
um but yeah like I I generally I have
faith me too yeah it's like this one
also has like a more narrow cast to I
feel like whereas the first one feels
like very big and Broad and they do a
lot of reminding you of the first one in
this one but yeah I thought this moved
it was you know Punchy of pace kept
momentum going uh I liked yeah the
expansions on both the lore of the world
as well as the expansion on seline's
Journey as this person sort of learning
that her whole life is based on these
systems uh built on deceit and trying
trying to you know get hip and and wake
up to those things and and carve out A
New Path and at least yeah from stepping
stone one to Stepping Stone 2 this has
been a cool journey I would love to to
see a more intense soundtrack I think
their scoring is great but like a theme
song bro like something that really
punches because this it's got such a um
identity to it this movie and if we had
some like I don't know man I'm really
feeling 9in Nails Nirvana like bring the
heat Yeah well yeah get yourself like uh
that first Matrix had a soundtrack where
it was just like industrial and and kind
of metalesque music and it was like
needle drops on needle drops but that
also felt like parts of the score along
with the score yeah I like a needle drop
I know some people don't but that does
work for me typically it depends I'd be
curious to see it here I don't I don't
find myself missing that so much but um
I remember you know other movies like
this have that and it's easy to imagine
it having that so yeah I mean you know
maybe you give it to me John let me have
my thing it won't bother you it's for
you all these songs no it's for you it's
for you guys at home for the best of you
guys here's what we can swear if we end
up doing the next one leather oh we'll
be in leather latex latex PVC Whatever
Whatever Gets a Job Done what's PVC is
it latex uh you know it's another that's
what her according to the comments her
costume is made of PVC and she said it
was absolutely like the most comfortable
thing to perform in seriously yes that's
what the comment that it was comfortable
yeah cuz I guess PVC is like it has that
leather look but it's like flexible and
lightweight so you know uh okay costume
designers come through let's go Comfort
matters cuz part of me sees a suit like
that I'm like God you must be like
sticking and sweating and all sorts of
stuff but apparently not all right well
if you want to see us in that then make
sure you like comment subscribe all that
good stuff thank you so much for being a
reject and we will see
you after after a patron shout out next
time after a patron shout out
yeah that's what I was hoping you would
say always it's always time for Patron
shout out recently I they I haven't been
doing any Patron shout outs I mean if
you don't want to do it we don't have to
do it I always want to do it I want to
shout out the sexiest of the sexies fine
pick one then jez you can just do the
whole thing you know who is sexy who Lex
Lex is sex e yes you can't just say that
he's you know like you got to it so we
we maybe we'll call Lex Lexi it's like
a uh she told me not to no oh okay okay
Lex you rock yeah because Lex is the
Beck of the hex and no hex for Lex
because Lex is sexy true that yeah and
you can't deny it n nobody would getting
getting fed
Stacks yeah for sure you're getting
Stacks uh um and
that's what's next what's next yeah
heyy and stay
pledged stay plexed stay don't be
perplexed just stay pledged not many
words and an X which makes
Lex unique mhm and Doper I also I'm
rocks I have an ex in my name and I know
that having an ex means that you are the
the you've got the X Factor and your
extreme oh and your extra oh hey those
are all and you're extraordinary oh
you're extraord you're so extraordinary
you made John drop I destroyed the the
computer here what did it type nothing
actually it just created another notch
on the patrons to shout out Lex is so
dope that he created all another line
that's right and just for you we're
going to shout you out twice this month
rice even yep that's the point who knows
okay thank you for being a super sexy
reject We Appreciate You Lex and thank
you to everybody else okay later
[Music]
woo